cam newton going to the la chargers
would be what chris
perfect to me i mean that to me is the
perfect fit you know from all aspects
business on the field there's nothing i
don't like about that marriage now
listen maybe the chargers know something
i don't maybe they know cam newton wants
30 million dollars a year i i don't know
i don't know those nuances but i just
look at the chargers with lack of
notoriety there in la compared to the
other team here's a chance where the
rams are you know kind of retooling todd
gurley's not there anymore guys are kind
of you know they're retooling their team
right now there's a chance to kind of
take over a little bit
and you got a legit top five defense
with some superstars there
and you're improving your offensive line
and a guy like cam newton not only gonna
sell tickets and billboards and
everything like that but you know like i
said the tom brady factor he's gonna
make them feel like they're a contender
to be a a an afc you know
afc championship type football team the
second he walks in the locker room if
he's healthy and everything checks out
that way so that's where i look at it
and and kind of love that fit
and let's talk about la the rams have
jared goff if the chargers would get cam
newton and he was healthy isn't that
no-brainer he's the better quarterback
yes for me it is yes i mean you know my
thoughts on jared goff i you know solid
quarterback do i think he's in the top
half of the league is quarterback
absolutely not i think jared goff is
somewhere between 17 and 20 or 22
somewhere in that range cam newton when
healthy is a top 10 quarterback there's
no doubt about it he's a game changer
not only for his own team but like we
talked about in the first hour he
changes how defenses have to play you
because of his interesting skill set and
that's where you know he fits anthony
lynn who's an ex running backs and a
running back coach they could play ball
control they got some big targets at
receiver with williams and keenan allen
and hunter henry to me there's just a
lot of things that make sense with cam
newton in the chargers
the challenge for the chargers is when
do they move do they move now and do
they hinge the contract on him passing a
physical that would be administered by
team doctors later and then if he fails
that physical you just rip it up and he
moves on elsewhere or do you wait to
have a proper physical or do you just
take the the leap of faith do you have a
a neutral outside doctor administer a
physical and you sign him and you pay
him and you just hope it works out these
are challenges that the chargers gonna
have to resolve because if they wait
another team could swoop in so let's
move on to the next team cam newton
going to the patriots would be what
chris
very interesting
uh that's where i mean i would love to
see it that would be i mean amazing cam
newton replaces tom brady and you know
of course they're going to change the
offense if that's the case to where yeah
they're going to make it suit cam newton
and his skill set a little bit you know
so it would be fun to for one to watch
belichick and mcdaniels
kind of reorganize and re-orchestrate
their offensive attack
but then to see cam newton who i think
is one of those guys who probably could
go into new england and not be
intimidated by like oh i'm replacing the
great tom brady and having to deal with
that i think he can handle that type of
pressure it would be interesting i don't
know if it's realistic but i do think if
there's a team who needed to conform to
a guy like cam newton new england could
definitely do it
you know they tell me that they're
working on a game of pft bingo where the
squares are the things that you and i
like to say over and over and over again
and one of my squares i'm told will be
cam newton is 2-0 all time against the
patriots he is 2-0 all-time against the
patriots and we've seen the patriots
become
paralyzed defensively when that play
that's been designed by bill belichick
to work against an offense breaks down
and it becomes backyard football that's
when they can't stop a mobile
quarterback because they don't have the
athletes to chase a cam newton down once
he starts to improvise and that's the
key and that's why they should be
interested in a cam newton now will cam
newton be willing to
leave his wardrobe at home and not you
know be as individualistic and creative
and different or will bill belichick
just say fine you want you want to be a
free spirit you want to be your own guy
we will relax it some like we did with
rob gronkowski that would be an
interesting culture clash between the
way the patriots do things and the way
cam newton does things but
yeah and this is why the chargers should
move quickly because the longer bill
belichick has to let this percolate and
he looks at jared stidham and brian
hoyer and he goes back and watches film
of what cam newton has done against the
patriots and against other teams when
he's healthy man at some point i've
become very intrigued by the possibility
of cam newton to the patriots chris all
right let's move on to the next one i
want to get them all in cam newton going
to washington where he'd be reunited
with his only nfl head coach ever ron
rivera that would be what chris
weird i just think weird right now with
the current state at the the washington
redskins i mean hey dwayne haskins he's
a top 20 pick you know kyle allen's
there you know kyle allen the same guy
who were at one point last year people
were trying to tell me that oh the
carolina panthers are better with kyle
allen than cam newton yeah bullcrap they
were okay
but but i just i yeah i just don't think
that is a good i just don't see it being
a good fit for really either guy
i don't and and i'm not so sure ron
rivera you know wants to deal with that
maybe he wants to build something new
here in washington all together i'm sure
he's got great respect for cam newton
but uh i think right now you gotta go
with what the assets you got and you
gotta see what dwyane haskins is as a
quarterback first before you you try to
find somebody to replace him
yeah i think to answer this one i say it
would be exhausting specifically for ron
rivera i've detected a fatigue among
panthers fans and among media about just
when is he going to be healthy when is
he going to stay healthy is he going to
stay healthy is he going to take a hit
is he going to be able to keep going
what is it going to be this offseason
that we're trying to overcome and i
think ron rivera i think one of the
reasons he brought kyle allen with him
and did that trade having kyle allen
even though it didn't make the team
better it removed from that pile of
stuff you have to worry about your
quarterback getting injured and your
quarterback's health and the constant
questions and i think from ron rivera's
standpoint having to constantly deal
with the media questions about cam
newton i think from regardless how he
feels about the player i think he's
happy to put that bag down for good and
i don't think he'd want it and i don't
think cam would want it you know cam's
going to want to go to a place where he
thinks he's going to be able to win and
there are better options frankly right
now than washington if his goal is to
try to win all right the next one and
this is one i thought of yesterday cam
newton going to the miami dolphins would
be what
i i don't think smart for the miami
dolphins right now i think that miami
dolphins first off with shan galey i'm
not so sure he could adapt to
an offense around cam newton and i think
more with the miami dolphins right now
you're trying to build something for the
future
and you know again cam newton i just we
don't know how long
you know he's gonna play is the team
gonna sign him to a one two year type
contract to me if i'm the miami dolphins
right now i'm trying to build something
that can be you know
build it with a quarterback that i see
really fits the way brian flores i think
wants to coach his football team and
wants to play offensive football and i
just don't see cam newton being that fit
i think it would be cool to see him stay
on south beach and everything like that
but one i don't think cam newton wants
to go to a team like miami that's kind
of in the rebuild mode like you're
saying and two i don't know if i think
it's necessarily the right move for the
miami dolphins right now to go that
direction
i love the market for cam newton i love
the idea of him being in miami and brian
flores was there in new england when he
saw cam newton and you can go ahead and
put it on the bingo card again went 2-0
against the new england patriots and and
ryan fitzpatrick is their starter right
now and we've seen this kind of
aggressive all-in you know you say
they're rebuilding why are you signing
10 free agents right out of the gates
when it costs more that week the first
week of free agency than what at any
other time i think that the dolphins are
not going to sit around and wait
and i think the longer cam newton is
available the more intrigued brian
flores is going to be by the possibility
and i think it is a sneaky strong
possibility because they want to play
they want to win and oh by the way cam
newton if he can function against bill
belichick's defense why wouldn't you
want him on your team you're facing bill
belichick's defense twice a year
well those are good points mike you make
a lot of good points you're right about
that you know the one thing that i'll
say kind of dawned on me as i was
listening to you there too
if you are the miami dolphins and i'm
sure that their front the front office
personnel has watched all the
quarterbacks i'm sure the coaches are
kind of just getting through all that
type of stuff right now if you came away
not blown away by any of the
quarterbacks that you think oh i thought
this guy could be my franchise in the
future whether that's herbert or jordan
love or tua if you come away going being
underwhelmed by that group then maybe
cam newton is the player and you know
maybe you you you you just reevaluate
the quarterback position when that time
comes and you realize cam newton might
not be a part of your team in the future
but uh you know when i think about it
from that aspect you know i almost want
to change my answer it's not as crazy
and then you made a lot of good points
look at what the dolphins did a couple
of weeks ago before the nfl slammed the
door on the player visits to team
facilities they had
um
one of the running backs in i can't
remember which one i think it was jk
dobbins from ohio state he was in they
had jordan lovin i think before they
slammed the door they tried to get tua
in before they slammed the door it's
entirely possible and every team is
going to deal with it differently but if
we're going to go into a draft with
limited information you're going to go
safer you're not going to take risks and
if you didn't get a chance to properly
evaluate the most important position
in the sport you wait until next year
and maybe we see them
trade some of those picks for more picks
next year they were going to put more of
an emphasis on free agency maybe that's
why they signed 10 guys last week more
of an emphasis on available veterans
that we know about
less of an emphasis on incoming players
that we have no way of finding the
information that we need in order to be
the best possible selectors of talent
that we can be and you know you got 32
different teams they're going to be sort
of like snowflakes in that regard where
they all have a unique approach the
dolphins may be saying you know what
let's go all in with the draft next year
this year let's go all in with veterans
because at least we know about these
guys and that could cause them to i'm
talking myself into cam newton
i'm not gonna lie you've lawyered me
into it a little bit too the more
i sat here and done you know there's
some there are some positives here and
you're right with this weird year of the
draft and the evaluation process not
getting to know guys the uncertainties
there yeah like i said if you're not in
love with any of these guys that might
be a smart move i wish i could change my
answer uh i'm not that smart it's not
binding but either way i i i you've
persuaded me a little bit to think
differently about miami and cam newton
for sure all right we got to take a
break we had one more on the list it was
the cowboys but that was me that was
mainly kind of a troll thing that's not
gonna happen it's not gonna happen it's
not gonna happen but but that's the only
other team that we could even conceive
of as possibly being in the mix if they
get frustrated with dak prescott decided
to go a different way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports